- You were forced to
make creative decisions
based on the rules that you're given,
which is like you can't go back
and just do the same tricks over and over,
even the same looks.
(foreboding music)
(foreboding music continues)
First and foremost,
those two movies gave me
my initial relationship with James Wan.
To watch James and Leigh
reinvigorate the genre,
move the genre forward
and challenge themselves
from the guys who created "Saw"
to come back and really
turn this world on its head.
There was something about
the first "Insidious" movie
where because we're on
such a shoestring budget
shot over 20 something days,
you were forced to make creative decisions
based on the rules that you're given,
which is like turn off the lights,
that's the further in camera,
practical scares on a modest budget,
all those things that I really learned
from acting in the movies.
So it was a lot more
about just the concept
of how these "Insidious" movies work
that I think really reflect
in how I approached this one.
(suspenseful music)
You can't go back and
just do the same tricks
over and over even the same looks.
Even the budget of the
first "Conjuring" film
it was a whole different ballgame
from what we had on "Insidious" movies
and there's an expanse to
"The Conjuring" franchise
just simply because of money and time.
Even Leigh Whannell said to
me about this movie is that,
it felt bigger than
other "Insidious" movies,
and I think a lot of that
is my scope of a film
is not to keep it tiny.
I wanna be efficient and a
lot of this does take place
in his dorm room and those actions,
but I knew two people
with different coasts,
I wanted different looks, I
wanted daytime and nighttime.
I wanted different feels.
This movie is a little more expansive
and I think that's what
"Conjuring" taught me
that while sometimes it's
great to get down and dirty
and do a movie in a couple weeks,
it's also nice to have time,
certainly to be able to build out scares
which really have to be your set pieces
that define your movie.
(suspenseful music)
I just emailed with David the other day,
I mean, that's still one
of my proudest movies.
I think the efficiency, that doesn't sound
like a very creative word,
but after you've directed,
it's an incredibly valuable word.
We shot "Hard Candy" in 18 1/2 days.
I didn't even know you could do that.
I had come off of two
"Phantom of the Opera"
and the "Alamo," both these
just massive movies to me
that were six months at a time.
And all of a sudden, you're
gonna shoot this whole thing
in 18 1/2 days.
And it was David's first film.
What the movie lacked in expanse
and maybe even coverage and time,
he made up on the backend
with his color palette.
I think one scene maybe was cut.
I mean, he was so efficient and lien
in what he needed to make his story.
His efficiency of
shooting and color palette
was something that I
certainly admire to this day.
(suspenseful music)
One of the things that I
always loved about Stephen King
that I think has a real
throughline with "Insidious"
is having a very dark undercurrent
of some kind of emotional
or family distress,
and then completely
going balls to the wall,
wacky, supernatural, strange
from outer space aliens
in the same film.
I really love that.
I think this genre supports that
and no one writes that
better than Stephen King.
What "Insidious" is is having
this very core of this family
and in my movies, this family
dealing with the trauma
of nine years ago.
That's why I didn't mind taking
these very melodramatic
turns in the final act
because the "Insidious"
world warrants that.
I think it's okay in "Insidious,"
wouldn't have done it in "The Conjuring,"
different kind of thing.
Often actors and storytellers,
certainly from the theater,
they run from words
like camp or melodrama.
I think the supernatural element
of it is important to
the "Insidious" world.
James really dug into like
carnival souls and some,
even his makeup design and that.
And while I didn't really do that,
I certainly feel an
influence of Stephen King,
the painting at the end.
To me, I just felt like, sure, yeah,
let's do something
really bold and strange.
And also I had to confine
it into a space for time
and everything else.
So I was actually trying to think
of the Stephen King element
that make really like get
those stories so spectacular
to start with something very
basic and real and brutal,
and then just go completely
into another world.
I think horror allows that
specifically Stephen King horror
and that's something that we did certainly
with "In the Tall Grass."
You gotta just dive
right in, touch the rock.
(suspenseful music)